mics and oh ESPN national NFL columnist
and had a long long article on the
mothership where espn.com where he's
talking about let's rank the top
starting quarterbacks here let's get
some information here let's get some
anonymous quotes from people behind the
scenes here about these quarterbacks and
Mike joins us now Mike how are you this
morning I'm doing great
explain to me how this came about where
you could get these executives or front
office people or Scouts coaches to dish
on these starting quarterbacks
anonymously you know well I've been
covering the league for 20 years and the
last five years I've really been
fortunate to have this job as a
columnist for ESPN Insider where I'm not
you know unlike if you're a beat writer
nowadays I'm not running the Twitter
with everything I know and I'm not
having to you know write 50 times a day
and post on a blog so I get together and
I get to know a lot of people in the
league so there's a lot of trust and
that's really where it all starts and
and you know I enjoy that part of it
I've learned so much about basically
this is how the league views guys right
it's not right it's not wrong this is
the league view the writer right or
wrong this is it how did you go about
deciding what to print on certain
quarterbacks yeah it's a great question
I feel like if if the criticism then I
need to do the research to kind of see
if it's true and so for example if
somebody says this is you know people
don't think that Tyrod Taylor is as good
of a passer you know and so when you get
into third and long can you pass well I
looked up and said geez I didn't know
this the last three years he's he's
number one and percentage of passes
going for first downs on third and seven
but 37 so take that people who didn't
think that so you know there's a balance
in knowing whether you know in going
with something I have to feel like it's
fair to give the criticism at the same
time you you get some juicy ones that
you just want to use so you're walking
that line who got the most most reaction
which quarterback
that's a great question I would say
Garoppolo Garoppolo is the most
interesting one he and Watson are
probably the two and for them to sneak
into the second tier it's funny I'll
give you a quote that didn't make it in
on Garoppolo it's very funny to me at
least it was very funny in light of his
recent the recent revelation of his
dating choice there was one guy in this
poll who put Garoppolo in the top tier
okay 1 out of 50 I'm like really the
guys played what five six games you're
putting him in the top tier he said look
a Tier one quarterback
is like porn you know it when you see it
and I thought you know I'm gonna leave
that out I mean I need to put that and
then why I started dating choice I
thought geez I should have put that in
okay you have it feels like people are
on you know opposite ends when it comes
to Garoppolo then I haven't seen enough
to put him even as a you know a top like
a two tier I just haven't seen enough
there but it feels like he looks like
handles himself he's Patriot pedigree
that we just we're kind of shoving him
in that you're gonna be you're gonna be
a top flight quarterback damn it but
then there are other people who go yeah
it's obvious can't you see all the
attributes he has did you find like who
had the most polar opposite of opinions
attached to them well I would say
Garoppolo and Flacco where I believe
there may been one other one or the only
guys who got votes in four different
tiers so that's a pretty big range in
Gruffalo's case if you put them in the
fourth year you're just saying hey I've
seen enough the guys played you know
played only a few games so that's kind
of the fourth tier is really a couple
tears in it's here it's four it could be
for the Josh McCown who you just think
is not really you know we know what he
is and it's not that great or it could
be somebody who's exciting but hasn't
played enough so that's where he got his
Flacco though to get seven votes in the
in a second tier or where did he get yes
seven in the second tier he had two in
the fifth year two people are done with
them they're just like you know I'm
tired almost like I'm tired look at him
I don't think it
starter anymore and we'll see this here
did you hear from anybody
after this list came out yeah definitely
I get texts from people who are in the
survey coordinators coaches you know
some of them are just you know making
fun of my hair on TV and others are
saying good job others are saying I
can't believe who's the guy who told you
as I don't tell them that but I these
are what I want to do is like let people
in on the conversations that people in
the league are having you know and I
think this is a great sort of vehicle
for doing that what was the fan reaction
you gun well the fan reaction number one
the first mist you know the people are
like think it's my rankings like I did
it you know well I'm not invested I
didn't have a vote I mean why would I
I'm not in the league and then I think
you know I live in the Seattle area so I
always tease brach here you know he's on
the radio here in any any criticism of
Russell Wilson I mean Brock's all over
me so there's been a fair amount of
pushback that why isn't Wilson in the
top tier he's very close and I think if
they take some the playoffs this year
they'll be there but you know when he
came up with that great defense in
Marshawn Lynch you don't get the full do
until you go a couple years without
thought without those things on your
side and he's gonna do that again this
year he's Mike Sando ESPN national
columnist for the NFL joining us Dan
Patrick show drew Brees
caught some some shrapnel he'll hear I
was I was kind of surprised were you you
know I wasn't but that was the biggest
surprise - I believe Luis Riddick when I
was we were doing the NFL live show and
he really pushed back on the fact that I
was look at Drew Brees well only six and
tear - so 44 of the 50 had him in Tier
one which I think that's where he
belongs but there's what happens is when
you talk to this many people not
everybody has watched 25 hours of Drew
Brees tape in the last two weeks right I
mean some people are just like you know
what we played him last year and man the
ball was floating in the second half of
that game and that's sort of what sticks
out to them so you get a few of those
types of so somebody got a couple of
those um Brees and I think that's great
information to have somebody who really
knows
and who saw him up close thought there
was some slippage in the waste throwing
the ball out of the way back of her head
doesn't mean it's a bad quarterback
doesn't mean he's not Tier one but no
one's saying that about Brady and no
one's saying that about Rodgers his
Rogers on a tear of his own well I think
he is from just physically playing the
position you know you have to sort of
separate that from the fact that you
know there's team results here - and Tom
Brady's are better so how do you take
into account those two things negative
comments on Rodgers no and I was kind of
like it was funny as I finished doing
this thing for you talk to all these
people and then you realize that you put
the energies we didn't talk that much
about the guys who everybody just has
one on right I mean what is there more
to say but I tried to see if people were
concerned about his health because he's
missed 16 games over the last five
seasons missed half the year just about
last year and there wasn't a ton of
concern among people in the league on
that so I don't think anyone's concerned
about how he's playing it's just a
matter of is he gonna be hurt still
feels like the jury's out on Cam Newton
not quite sure what to make of Cam
Newton was that a fair assessment of the
reaction I think the jury's back on
kanya dignity but but you're right you
know on another level he had the exact
same average as he had a year ago the
problem is he's just different from
everybody else so it's hard to apply a
template for evaluating him most people
in the league this is true whether you
talk to a cornerback in the league a
defensive coordinator to really get the
highest level of respect they have to
feel like you're a deadly accurate
passer from the pocket because when you
don't have a good defense when you're
behind late in the game whether you can
run a power or rush as a quarterback
isn't gonna be the difference you have
to put points on the board spin in the
football and people don't think he's a
consistently eyecare passer on the other
hand could they gain an inch without him
I mean the whole offense run through
them in a way that it doesn't for even
the best guys the guys in tier 1 aren't
running the ball on power plays like he
does like he runs fluid plays like a
running back so how do you evaluate them
does the template apply to him
does but it doesn't fit as perfectly as
on the other guys and so his ability to
run and the value he provides and that
pushes him up higher if he didn't have
that I then he'd be he'd be down in Tier
three for sure I was surprised to the
Jared golf gave you a great season Jimmy
Garoppolo is gave you five games at the
end of the year in games that didn't
mean anything
why is Garoppolo highly more highly
thought of than Jared gone well I think
there's a lot of credit to go around
with the Rams because Sean McVeigh was
the hot young play color Todd Gurley was
an MVP candidate they went with a were a
team that you know he was in the worst
possible situation starting seven games
as a rookie with a prehistoric offense
and no guys around him Gurley was hurt
being in a great situation so I think
people said in the end when it was on
him and they needed to score some points
against Atlanta to win a playoff game or
when it was on him in the first Seattle
game late in the game he did almost
actually put him ahead late but he
didn't he didn't finish as well when it
was on his shoulders I think people are
saying look you had a terrible rookie
season we're not going to hold that
fully against you but we did see you do
it again before we're all gonna push you
in to the second tier where as Garoppolo
is sort of the perfect if you were to do
this in a laboratory right we're trying
to figure out how much of it is the
quarterback how much of it is the team
well you know in Houston and you know in
San Francisco what those teams looked
like with and without their guys and it
was night and day difference and for
sure Garoppolo he's getting a bump for
that I think that's why he comes out on
the optimistic end I'll leave you with
this Mike and this is separate from your
your poll that you had your rankings if
you could know the absolute truth about
the following which one would you choose
Malcolm Butler being benched Jimmy
Garoppolo being traded deflategate or
other with the Patriots I would say
Butler being benched is one of the great
mysteries the other ones we can sort of
fill in some of the blanks they've been
covered well we don't really have all
that great of reporting on this one and
it's the pivotal
thing I mean in a game decided by I was
gonna say inches but hundreds of yards
for each team you know the ball was
flying up and down the field how can
that be he was active for the game I
mean if this is a decision during the
week you need that roster spot don't you
yeah I mean that's baffling baffling for
one of the greatest coaches of all time
or the greatest coach what do you think
happened why don't you get some of your
executives to help you there this is
what I want to find out Mike not what
they think a Drew Brees thrown the ball
30 yards down the field well it's funny
I guarantee I have in my notes some of
the theories or what people have heard
and backchannels am I prepared to you
know go with that right now I wouldn't
do that I don't even remember exactly
what the series were but I loved it it's
on my mind now I'm gonna go to like
training camps who are starting tomorrow
for a week and I'm gonna I'm gonna fish
on it more because it's crazy it is
absolutely and I'm I guarantee you those
Patriots who are still on the team want
to know the answer to it at least you
would think it has to come out how does
it come out it's New England it doesn't
you know there's stuff they they're
pretty good keeping it in-house the fact
that it did not even a whiff of it even
Malcom Butler and maybe Butler doesn't
say anything because he's embarrassed by
it but if he felt like you know it this
was heavy-handed by Belichick then you
would have thought he would have done
something to save face yeah absolutely I
you know in some of these things you
wonder if only bill knows for sure the
full extent of it you know what is the
whole well I got imagine Robert Kraft
probably said Bill and after bill come
here Foreman what happened what happened
with Malcolm what happened to the guy
who won us a Super Bowl a couple years
ago bill could you tell me about that
yeah we're all what if bill said no what
does Bill say guy hey pal sorry what's
he gonna do fire him what have you just
said you mister crap we're on just we're
on to the second half he could what's
anyone go check yeah hey pack your bags
we're gonna go with another guy mister
mister graph we're on to the second half
all right leave me alone
Mike Congrats on all the recognition on
it great great work here hard work and
we appreciate your time
hey thank you very much that's some
likes and OH ESPN national NFL columnist
he was good some good stuff there for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]